Voiceover: What I want to do in this video
is start introducing and
we've already talked about him
a little bit.
So actually they've
already been introduced,
but maybe flesh out a little
bit more Keynesian thinking.
This right here is a picture
of John Maynard Keynes
and I often mispronounce him as Keynes,
because that's how it's spelled,
but it's John Maynard Keynes.
He was an economist who did a lot
of his most famous work
during the Great Depression,
because in his view,
classical models did not seem
to be of much use during
the Great Depression.
To understand this a little bit better,
let's compare purely
classical aggregate supply
aggregate demand models to maybe one
that's more Keynesian.
Some of what we've talked about -
Keynesian, I should say.
I already did my first mispronunciation.
One that's a little bit more Keynesian.
Keynesian right over here.
In some of the conversations,
we've already begun
to introduce a little bit
of Keynesian thinking,
but in this video we're going to try
to show the difference between the two
and it's not to say that one
is right or one is wrong.
In fact, Keynesian felt
that in the long run,
the classical model actually made sense,
but he also famously said,
"In the long run we are all dead."
I also want to emphasize
that this isn't a defense
of Keynesian economics.
There are some points
to what he has to say,
but there are other schools of thought.
Unfortunately, they
often get very dogmatic,
but they also have some reasons to be wary
of Keynesian economics
and we hope to go over
some of that in future videos.
In this one, we just want to understand
what Keynesian economics is all about
and how it really was
a fundamental departure
from classical economics.
In classical economics, I'm going to use
aggregate demand and
aggregate supply in both.
This is classical, this is
price, this right over here
is real GDP and I'm going to do it
for the Keynesian case, as well.
This is price and this
right over here is real GDP.
In both views of reality, or both models,
you have a downward sloping
aggregate demand curve
for all the reasons
that we've talked about
in multiple videos.
That's aggregate demand right over there.
We've already seen it,
the classical view is that
in the long run, an
economy's productivity,
or productive capacity,
or its output shouldn't
be dependent on prices.
We've seen the long run
aggregate supply curve
something like this.
This is the aggregate
supply in the long run,
or sometimes you'll have
long run aggregate supply.
Sometimes it'll be referred to that.
Saying, look, all prices
are, they're a way to signal
what people want and demand
and things like that,
but at the end of the
day, prices and money,
they're just facilitating transactions.
You go to work and you
get paid and all that,
but then you go and use
that money to go and buy
other things that the economy produces,
like food and shelter and transportation.
All money is is a way of
facilitating the transactions,
but the economy, in theory,
based on how many people
it has, what kind of technology it has,
what kind of factories it has,
what kind of natural resources
it has, it's just going
to produce what it's going to produce.
If you were to just
change aggregate demand,
if the government were to print money
and aggregate demand were to -
and just distribute it from helicopters,
in this classical model,
you would just have
aggregate demand shift to
the right, but you have
this vertical long run
aggregate supply curve
so the net effect is it
didn't change the output
in this classical model.
All that happens is that the price goes
from this equilibrium price
to this equilibrium price
over here.
You have the price would go up
and you would just experience inflation
with no increased output
and there's multiple ways
you could've shifted that
aggregate demand curve
to the right.
You could have a fiscal
policy where the government,
maybe it holds its tax revenue constant,
but it increases spending, or it goes
the other way around.
It does not decrease, it
doesn't change its spending,
but it lowers tax revenue.
Either of those, it tries to
pump money into the economy
and pushes that aggregate
demand curve to the right.
In this purely classical
view, it says in the long run,
that's not going to be any good,
just will lead to inflation.
The only way that you
can increase the output
of economy is by making
it more productive.
Maybe making some
investments in technology,
make the economy more efficient,
maybe your population grows.
The only way is to really
shift this curve to the right
on the supply side right over here.
Keynes did not disagree with
that, but he sitting here
in the middle of the
Great Depression, saying,
"Look, all of a sudden
people are poor in the 1930s.
"Factories did not get blown
up, people didn't disappear.
"In fact, there are
factories that want to run,
but they are being shut
down, because no one
"is demanding goods from them.
"There are people who
want to work, but no one
"is asking them to work.
"They could work and produce
wealth that could then
"be distributed to -
"But no one's demanding
for them to do it."
He suspected something weird was happening
with aggregate demand,
especially in the short run.
In a very pure, very,
very short run model,
I know we have talked about a short run
aggregate supply curve
that is upward sloping.
Something that might
look something like that.
That is actually starting to put some
of the Keynesian ideas into practice.
What I like to think of
is something in between,
but if you think in the
very, very, very short term,
Keynes would say prices are
going to be very sticky.
Especially in the short
run, and I'll call it
the very short run, you have,
especially if the economy's
producing well below
its capacity, like it seemed to be doing
during the Great Depression,
prices are sticky.
That makes intuitive sense.
If the economy's trying to get overheated,
people are being overworked, you want them
to work more, hey, I want overtime.
You want factories to operate
faster, people are going
to start -
The utilization is high, people
are going to start charging
more and more, but if I'm
unemployed and I'm desperate
to work, I'm not going
to ask for a pay raise.
If my factory is at 30%
utilization and someone wants
to buy a little bit more, that's
not the time that I'm going
to say, "Hey, I'm going
to raise prices on you."
I'll say, "Yeah, exact same price.
"You want another 5% of
my factory to be utilized?
"Sure, that sounds great."
In the very short run,
it has the opposite view
of the aggregate supply curve
than the classical model.
It says at any level of
GDP in the short run,
prices won't be affected.
It won't be affected.
So in this model right over
here, this is aggregate supply
I'll call it, in the very short run.
You can debate what short
run or very short run means,
whether we're talking
about days, weeks, months,
or even a few years here,
but once you start looking
at the world this way,
then something interesting happens.
In this model right over
here, the only way to increase
GDP was on the supply side.
In this model right over
here, the only way to increase
GDP is on the demand
side, to actually either
through monetary policy, print more money,
or through fiscal policy, lower taxes
while holding spending
constant or maybe do both,
essentially deficit spending.
Someway, without holding taxes constant,
but the government's
spending more, whatever.
Shift the curve to the right
and that might be a way
to increase the overall output.
Keynes' real realization was that, look,
the classical economist
would tell you if you have
a free and unfettered market,
the economy will just get
to its natural, very efficient state.
Keynes says, "Yes, that is sometimes true,
"but that's sometimes not true."
We'll talk about different cases.
By no means do I think the Keynesian model
is the ideal and I don't think even Keynes
would have thought the Keynesian model
describes everything.
Depends on the circumstance.
Keynes would say, "Look, let's think
"of a very simple idea."
You have person A, person
B, person C, and person D.
Let's say person A sells
to person B, person B sells
to person C, person C sells to person D,
and person D sells to person A.
Let's say that they're
all selling two units
of whatever good and
service that they offer.
For whatever reason, let's
say C, all of a sudden,
just got a little bit
pessimistic, had a bad dream,
woke up on the wrong
side of the bed and says,
"You know what?
"I'm not feeling so
good about the economy.
"I'm going to hold off
from my purchase from B.
Instead of two units, I'm
going to purchase one unit.
Well, B says, "Well,
gee, my business is bad.
"Now I'm only going to purchase one unit."
A does the same thing for the same reason,
D does the same thing.
Now it all came back to C and now C says,
"Wow, I was right, that
dream was predictive."
It was a self-fulfilling prophecy.
Now they're going to operate in this state
and there might not be any
natural way to get them
bumped up to that state
where they're all buying
two units from each other
without maybe some outside,
especially some government act
or maybe all of a sudden saying,
"Hey B, if C doesn't want
to buy two, I'm going
"to buy two temporarily."
There are dangers to this, huge dangers,
and we'll talk about
that in future videos,
but then someone else,
let's say the government,
tries to shift the aggregate demand curve
through fiscal policy and they say,
"Hey, I'll buy one from you, B."
Then B says, "Okay, now
I can buy two again,"
and A can buy two again and
then D can buy two again
and then C can buy two again.
Then in an ideal world,
and this is the danger
of the government, the
government would step back
and say, "Okay, everything is fine again.
"I don't have to buy this."
As we know, it's very
hard once the government
starts spending money in
some way, to actually cut
this spending right over here.
This was the general
idea behind the Keynesian
versus the classical.
He says, "Look, there are circumstances,
"like the Great Depression,
where the economy
"is operating well below its potential
"and in those circumstances,
you need to have
"a stimulus on the demand
side, not just a supply side."
The correct answer, as with all things,
is probably something in between.
A probably more accurate
model is something like this.
Let's draw ...
This is price, this is
real GDP right over here
and we'll still draw our downward sloping
aggregate demand curve and
the more accurate thing
might look something like this.
Let's say that this is the absolute
theoretical maximum output,
if everyone in the country
isn't sleeping, the
factories are just being run
to the ground, that's the
absolute theoretical output.
Let's say that this is its potential.
Just a healthy state where the economy
might be operating.
The real medium run
supply curve or short run
aggregate supply curve.
This is aggregate supply
in the very long run.
This is the long run aggregate supply.
The best model would be
something that's in between
and might look something like this.
Our aggregate supply curve
might look something like -
I want to do it in a different color.
Let me do it in magenta.
It might look something like this.
For whatever reason, maybe
someone has a bad dream
or a bunch of people have a bad dream
or something scary
happens, aggregate demand -
The stock market crashes,
something happens,
aggregate demand shifts over there.
When we're out here, now all of a sudden
our output is well below
potential, we have a lot
of excess capacity and now
the Keynesian ideas seem
maybe they'll make sense.
Maybe there should be
some outside stimulus happening.
On the other side, if we're
performing well at potential,
then all of a sudden the
government wants to do
Keynesian policies and
we'll see in future videos,
the government will always want
to do Keynesian policies,
even if they're not justified.
It will push aggregate demand out here
and then the net effect is,
especially the more
vertical this is, the more
this net effect will be true,
that you really just get
more inflation and you
don't really get a lot
of increase in output.
It really depends on the circumstance,
but an aggregate supply
curve that starts flat
at low levels of output
and then gets higher
and higher slope and
becomes almost vertical
in your high levels of
output, this is probably
a better model that
takes into consideration
both the classical and
the Keynesian ideas.